new in theaters this weekend Rambo last
blood ad astra and Downton Abbey what
will you see this is your weekend
tickets I finally came home the
defensively family I've ever known she's
got is me
[Music]
John Rambo is back for his fifth playful
romp in Rambo last blood when John
Rambo's niece is abducted by the Mexican
cartel he decides it's time for revenge
and if they're coming for him you better
believe he's gonna set up some home
alone traps Rambo style and bust out his
trademark bow and arrow if you're
someone who's going in to see how many
kills Rambo racks up in this movie
here's the current kill stats by movie
with of course Rambo for having the most
leaving a lot of work for Rambo this
time around this movies for you if
you're looking for an intense revenge
action movie this weekend you love any
of the other Rambo movies or if you're a
fan of these very real
Rambo recap videos Sylvester Stallone
has been posted it's over
[Music]
deep in the jungles of Burma a happy
group of mission what are you thinking
about I do what I do because of my dad
he was a hero he gave his life for the
pursuit of knowledge
[Music]
it's crazy out there there's fires
everywhere and plane crashes they're
calling it the surge ad astra comes out
this weekend astronaut major roy mcbride
played by Brad Pitt survives an incident
on the space station only to learn that
the incident may be connected to his
father who spaceship and crew went
missing 30 years ago with this knowledge
and the knowledge his father is still
alive he sent on a mission to find his
father and find out what happened and
what he's been up to
I'll be honest that's oversimplified
because the movie is said to be both
introspective and a visual spectacle
this movies for you if you like movies
like interstellar you like a movie with
a lot of stars in it or you like movies
with a lot of stars in it cuz it's in
space
[Music]
the king and queen are coming to Downton
what
I want every surface to gleam and
sparkle
I'm royal Lucien a parade under dinner
I'm going to have to sit down tell your
driver to ready the car to take you to
see Downton Abbey in theaters this
weekend in a continuation of the Downton
Abbey television series from BBC the
Crowley family on their staff are
readying the estate for a visit from
none other than the king and queen of
England this important visit is sure to
send the Abbey in - just as much drama
as we've come to expect from the six
seasons of the show this movie is for
you if you love a good period piece
you're a fan of the Downton Abbey TV
show and you want to see what happens
next or you figure since it's 2019 they
got a sneak a Yas Queen joke in there
somewhere and you just got to see that
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see and check back next week to see
the next animated movie from DreamWorks
[Music]